it's crazy you know it's crazy she's
saying that let me tell you i had a 26
gi bill never used it i got a couple
thousand dollars i stopped so
we had friends that you just had to take
like six courses or two courses whatever
it was and they would send you to 1200
bucks every month
whatever the course was it was you know
you could so guys weren't working and
they were just taking the gi bill that
would come to you
and then there were certain people that
are like nah i'm good man i'm going to
go out there you know do something else
but
i can see that pride level of you know
being high
then but today man it's it's
you know what i said to the guy here's
what i said to gnome yesterday i'm just
all night i've been thinking about this
conversation
it's so i said i said no let me ask you
a question i said i read your books i
watch your documentary he has a new
documentary that came out requiem of the
american dream
i may not even be pronouncing that word
right of
the american dream and so i said if i
had
a hundred students that knew nothing
about america
they don't have an opinion about america
like imagine if you took me at 18 i
don't really have an opinion about
america i wasn't a guy that paid
attention in history class
1.8 gpa guy i'm not like out all of a
sudden 21 i started reading books right
i said if i gave you 100 students that
went into your class
and you taught them by the time the
semester's over with they're going to
hate america
they're going to hate america you asked
them that questions i said because i
said everything you're talking about
it's like you know going and you know
what was the scariest part here's the
scariest part
60 years he's been a professor at mit
60 so imagine 60 years
of saying his philosophies and so my
brain went to my son my oldest son wants
to be a scientist
so guess what i'm selling them on mit
mit so i'm saying you're going to go and
be taught by
what the hell is a person i'm not saying
that's everybody
i'm not saying that's everybody but by
the way i mean a
i took noam chomsky to task in my book
fed up
b i at the root of the rot
at the federal reserve and this idea
that we can print all the money is what
we call the mit mafia
we call it the mit mafia because of how
economics
is taught how people are brainwashed at
that institution that is considered to
be
one of the the best economic
institutions in the country
the other one did you mention thomas
soul did you mention stanford
of course the opposite end of the of the
intellectual respect
and we need a lot more of them at the
fed than we need
the mit mafia well you've seen the
painting i have in my office the the one
with milton friedman in there you'd be
amazed how many people come and say
why would you put that guy on there all
he cared about was prophets
all he cared about his prophets right
you know the whole thing but milton
friedman the black guy he gets is
the fact that all he cared about was
prophets but we need more milton
friedman if anybody you don't like
ricky you've seen ricky's passion of
course ricky prior to working with us
never followed capitalism he wasn't like
a capitalism guy ricky was a guy that
grew up in a mexican
you know what do you want to call him
mutual cartel carter you know i don't
want to say but you know he's been into
whatever levels of his family very
powerful family he's been around that
for a while right he openly talks about
it himself
you know what's the first video i told
him to watch i said if you really want
to but but
i said i'm gonna give you a video to
watch but be very careful he says what's
that
i said if you watch one you're gonna go
down a rabbit hole you're gonna watch a
hundred of his videos well milton
friedman milton friedman
phil donahue when they talked about
greed
and he told phil donahue he says what do
you say about all these rich people that
are so greedy and all they care about is
money and then milton friedman said
you know it's always the other guy
that's greedy you're not the one that's
greedy it's always the other guy right
always the other guy that's greedy we
forget that we're greedy you're telling
me you're not greedy phil
people here are not greedy who's the
only one that's greedy the government
that's greedy nader's not greedy i'm
sorry but
you're being a little too naive that
whole part when he had the exchange if a
person wants to learn about economics
go down the rabbit hole of milton
friedman look what will happen to your
brain
a month later then go listen to the
opposing argument
and try to put those two together and
see what happens yeah
i mean to me all i thought about is
if kids are going to school and that's
going to be the influence
of like if a regular kid was sitting
there saying why would you love america
you're supposed to love your family
why would you love america why would you
love this why would you love them like
oh my gosh so
anyways i think there is a major shift
on the way kids are thinking and i hope
it doesn't go in the direction because
yesterday i was in our armenian podcast
this girl named sona was interviewing me
very professional she's been in the
media side
in la for a while you know done some
interviews larry king all that stuff
very attractive and very well spoken but
specifically on the armenian side
and we were talking about media she's
asking me all these different questions
about media
and uh what about armenians this what
about armenia is that and i said look
you have you have to realize what's
going on right now with uh
education she says armenia you know
do you have any opinions of what
happened i said armenia got bought by
china china put 14 billion dollars into
armenia
i said you realize once you do that
you're owned
by china so china's going around slo you
know yesterday a
couple people on chinese
what do you call a government went out
and tweeted you read the story that they
went out their own weibo not tweet about
india making fun of india look at india
they're doing 400 000 cases
the government officials are making fun
of india why india is going because
india doesn't want to go in bed with
china so they're taking shots at them
india's telling china we don't want you
and look what china is doing you don't
want us
no problem they have a vaccine shortage
no problem
look at the way they're controlling the
vaccine shortage
where is it coming from this is a very
interesting game plan these guys
have put together for the last 30 40
years and fyi one guy said something to
me says this is nothing new
this has been going on for a long time
this is chinese's you forget this is not
a 200 year old
nation this is not this is thousands
they're experts in the war what are you
talking
about clinic on war if you study that
part of the world
india and australia and new zealand are
kind of isolated economically
and china is everywhere else you think
eventually
somebody's going to get elected in india
and they're going to cave and cave in
you know do business with china and take
money from them
it depends on where we are i hope that
never happens because i think
i think if there's one country that that
is the one
china doesn't want to see the excel cxl
i think it's india
it's because of the demographics i think
it's in one point three one point what
is the number one point two one
is it one point the only country that
has a larger population in china yeah so
of course yeah see that that's the thing
china and india they have that's like
half the population in the world
if they figure out how to at this point
what is india figured out they got the
best engineers they produce some of the
best engineers they do what they don't
have is infrastructure they don't have
infrastructure
yeah i agree and but that's i mean hello
we're the united states of america
i mean we can't build roads here but we
can help them build roads
don't don't don't hit the infrastructure
button while we're on the topic of china
and everything that danielle talked
about
you actually your story with the world
war one of the world or two the vets
come in
it's it's actually the the timeline of
that it's actually amazing because
it kind of culminated in the late 50s
early 60s and that's probably why jfk
said
don't ask what your country can do for
you ask what you can do for your country
so it's interesting that that culminated
in that and that was when we had the
space race
i mean i just i got goosebumps when you
said science and mit
if we keep this space race going
then we'll figure out income inequality
if we can get rid of the teachers unions
that have just about i mean
if anybody doesn't understand that the t
post coronavirus
that the teachers unions do not have the
children's
best interests at heart thank you packed
then
look i i live in texas my kids have been
in
the classroom every single day social
distancing masks
be careful every single day of the
school year
my kids there are blueprints all across
america for how to do this all you need
is one school to get it right
and then replicate that's all you need
and yet you've got teachers unions in
chicago los angeles new york
holding out holding mothers and
mr moms absolutely i have to be careful
about that i get slaughtered by the dads
who are like i'm i'm the dad at home i'm
like okay
but keeping half of the income out of
the household because
one parent has to be there to supervise
virtual learning
and it is i mean if we cannot figure out
how to put
and this is something that people can do
by the way there is this thing called
the constitution we don't have to wait
for the
democrats and the republicans to duke it
out
we can get rid of collective bargaining
via the constitution
we forget that we have that we can get
rid of term limits via the constitution
how you have to
dust off the politicians in congress
right now they've been there for so long
but but there are things that can be
done
in this country with the constitution by
the people for the people
that don't revolve around politics
that's broken
but teachers unions have to go when you
think of the space race in the 50s
and the best era in this country we were
sending somebody to the moon
and kids were waking up and saying i
want to be an astronaut and their
parents like you want to be an astronaut
you better study your math you better
study your science but they wanted that
they had the desire
so i'm watching the modern day space
race today and i'm like go for it
you can't tell children to get excited
about math and science
but you can show them and they can want
to succeed and if we start home growing
our brain power as opposed to importing
it into our graduate degrees
graduate programs and then re-exporting
it to india and china
think of what we could do as a country
but you got to get rid of the teachers
unions first
daniel with the space race though i feel
like in the 50s and the 60s was such a
new thing are you kidding me we're going
to space like
what like mind blown now it's like elon
musk did another rocket today nassau did
another thing
it's so we take it for granted like i
don't feel like it's that
it has the allure that it had such
oh i don't know what's the number how
many people have been to
what 569. 569 humans have been to space
569 out of how many people like seven
billion no doubt that it's amazing
today but it's it's not what it was 10
billion
disagree buddy you think you think it
still has this dude you just hear the
statistics
569 out of eight seven eight billion
people have been are you like that's a
very special
what does that mean though that's
because of the track adam what were we
just talking about
controlling semiconductors controlling
science
right what if there's rare earths up
there what if we can mine some of that
stuff look i'm all about space i'm just
saying i think a lot of people
aren't look how many before prior to
1960 how many people had been to space
zero now a lot of people have been to
space
500 something people i just look i'm not
downplaying the importance of going to
space on you
i'm all about america you had a man
crush on musk
the lifestyle the lifestyle i'm just
saying i don't think that's right
now it's now you got you got musk and
bezos having a war and then when
that's good okay that's great i think
that's great and then it's so
trivialized that
musk will tweet at bezos like oh look
who can't get it up wink wink like
it's it's because he's a comedian no
yeah we'll be on snl design
i disagree with this i disagree with
this and i'll point you two things and
you can go look at the ratings on tv and
with the interest of the
of american people around the world
disclaimer father's a rocket scientist
you just offended him so i just want you
to know
that's back up that's correct my my my
mom's dad my grandfather was a machinist
making machine parts southern california
aerospace industry he was just a
machinist blue collar
but he was making parts for his
important stuff my dad guest was a
rocket scientist
mathematician i'm sorry for offending
your dad the rockets no no it's okay
it's okay screw you
[Laughter]
with a smile so there's two things that
you saw
one was and it goes back about it's like
six years ago
remember when the red bull stunt guy
felix went up to the
the edge of atmosphere and jumped it was
the highest skydive all the time did you
see how many people were watching that
and how interested they were
and all those things was going on there
was nothing going on but him talking to
the guy
going all the way up up up and then he
did it the second thing is when elon
musk
just what was it four months ago brought
the two
first two astronauts back astronaut dave
and astronaut bob whatever the guys
remember those astro dave astro bob and
he brought him back and they landed and
they showed up
picking the ship picking up the capsule
america was enthralled wow somebody
other than nasa pulled this off
go look at the ratings on that i i don't
think you're correct i think there's a
lot of
interest in what's going on there and
the people are pretty amazed that the
stuff
is happening whether it's nassar yeah i
mean what percentage of the country was
interested in that story
give me a number what percentage of the
country was interested in that story i
don't know but the ratings were huge
okay but just give me a percentage
and this is a very qualified moment to
say what the hell is your point
where are you going with this 100 of the
country was interested in 1960. maybe
it's 20 percent now
oh my god on all the trading floors on
wall street when they when they landed
the probe on mars
i mean cnbc bloomberg everything turned
off we watched we watched that landing i
mean
i just got space i mean i'm just talking
about that okay add this to your list
with women why haven't you been to the
moon since 1986. so tell us when you
were in high school in 1960s what was it
like when though
i got to tell you he's not going to
experience that
i think you just want to be an astronaut
in the ocean that's i think what you're
trying to do
i'm trying to get out there oh i get to
swim at some point very cool
i just i think it was yeah like a bigger
deal in the 60s than it is today
what i think she was the point she was
trying to make is to get kids to dream
again
yes let's go do the impossible whatever
the hell is the
i talked to a doctor is it michi akaku i
may not be saying the name right
you know who he is he's a theoretical
physicist he's like one of those
what's the french pronunciation of his
name listen i'm going to butcher it if
it's english or whatever
i actually think i got that one right
michio kaku the other one i i totally
butchered
so the asian guy yeah the white hair top
fifteen favorite interviews of all time
favorite enemies of all time top fifteen
stop stop stop go so so i'm talking to
him and i said so
tell me uh uh uh is there civilization
out there at this point of the game we
know there's civilization out there i
said
uh you said once you know let's stop
trying to find
out about them because if we do find out
about them what if they are
10 times more powerful than us right and
i said okay i said so here's a question
for you he says
i said do you think there's a twin of
america
and you know i'm not america of the uh
the earth out there as
in space another earth out there he says
i'm willing to bet there is and what's
scary is they may be millions of years
ahead of us you know what i said i said
i don't think that's possible he says
he says why do you think that is i says
you think
you really think this thing's going to
continue i say you don't think there's
an
end time to this he says what do you
mean i say you don't think
you think like we're gonna go the way
we're going right now and not
one insecure crazy offended i said what
happened in germany do you remember the
guy with the weird-looking mustache
do you know half the story why he did
what he did is because he was offended
because somebody offended him so he kept
that grudge for a long time
what are you gonna do if another kid
comes and gets offended
and he keeps it for years and all of a
sudden his vision is to destroy
everything you think
he says well that's level one you're
thinking about this i think internet's
gonna do this and
then we talked about whether we can uh
time travel he says that's a possibility
he says this is how you do time
but you know how it sounds crazy think
about if you sit there and say you know
what i want to go
to 1985. okay and then he explained how
how to go back in time it's just because
if you go back in time
and you save one of your parents from
dying or something now you're messing up
with the future and all this stuff
says then you're going to go into three
dimensions listen i honestly i felt like
i was on lsd and i was on no drugs at
that time
you've not seen ant-man yes of course i
haven't i have but the whole thing
is look it was like it was like
how do i describe this to you it was uh
uh it was
what was the word that we started off
with the the the section
the same sexual it was honesty porn for
sapiosexual community
that's what it was okay that's a good
way of putting it right that's what it
was
because you just listened to this guy
like oh my gosh
now can we time travel i don't know the
fact that somebody thinks we can't
that's exciting to want to go out there
and do the impossible so
adam to the community of people that
party with you in miami that could care
less about what we can invent
we respect them a lot we salute them
tremendously
but to the other community that wants to
find out what the hell is in space
i applaud them to go find out i'm
actually very curious myself
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye